there will be a meeting of home affairs
ministers this time and they will
discuss the implementation of the
European agenda on migration the
Commission presented two main proposals
regarding asylum seekers so relocation
and resettlement so ministers will
discuss this package the implementation
of these decisions and how we are going
to relocate or resettle 60,000 people in
need of international protection it's
40,000 for relocation and 20,000 for
resettlement a relocation in the is the
transfer of a person who is already in a
member state that should be responsible
to process the asylum application to
another member state then resettlement
is asylum seekers people in need of
international protection that are
outside the European Union so we
transfer them directly from outside the
you to inside the you we will discuss
how we are going to distribute these
people among the different member states
the safe countries of origin is a
principle that it's included in the
asylum procedures directive that means
that you can process faster an
application if a person comes from a
safe country that means that the country
is let's say has good relations with the
European Union has a close relationship
or the political situation is stable
you